millionaires and people who have
incredible wealth
leave clues there are seven things that
you can do
to attract wealth into your life and you
can start right now number one is
examine your relationship with money
because you do have a relationship with
money do you worry about it slipping
through your fingers do you hold on to
it are you scared of spending when did
you tip only a tiny amount because you
really haven't got enough and you're in
that scarcity mindset look at how you
hold on to money how you worry do you
say things like
i can't find the money which in itself
is kind of weird because nobody finds
money do you say money slips through my
fingers i can't hold on to money when
you examine these expressions
they're not even true
so look at how you talk about money how
you feel about money boost your
self-worth by saying things like i
deserve money
i'm worth money i have an amazing skill
set i deserve to monetize this gift i've
got i have a gift
and i can monetize what i can do
create is worth financial investment so
don't think things like i'm going to
write a book no one's going to read it
i'm going to open a shop nobody will
come do the opposite i have a phenomenal
product everyone's going to fall in love
with this product
i'm monetizing a gift and if i believe
in it so much because it's worth
believing in
so will everyone else commit
to achieving
financial abundance i've just been in
someone else's documentary about how to
become an entrepreneur
how to make money yourself it has never
been easier there are so many youtube
tutorials
and instagram posts where you can find
out how to create wealth how to create a
product how to sell a product how to be
good at selling
good at finding funding good at
promoting something you have for
instance do you want to write a book
i've just written my seventh book you've
got to be really good at promoting a
book it's not enough to write a great
book not even maybe you have to learn
how to
promote that book write articles about
your book go on shows and blogs and talk
about your book because if you want
something
you're gonna have to learn something
anything of significance that you want
will require you learning something new
like marketing for instance and if you
can learn marketing
you can make a lot of money by marketing
an amazing product even if it's not your
product be productive not busy you can
get more done
in less time when you focus it's so easy
to go i'm going to write a book let me
sharpen my pencils do some spell check
get everything just right just get on
with it
sit down and focus on what you're doing
you can get more done in less time when
you just narrow your thoughts down
wealth is also a state of mind you see
you can be a generous person generous
with your time
generous with compliments generous with
help don't think i haven't got any money
and so
i can't really go to this place i've got
to turn up with gifts or i'm poor don't
have a poor mentality have a generous
mentality give a lot of yourself and
when you can give
a lot of yourself you can get so much
back people who are wealthy give more
you know and i'm working with a client
and i go oh sorry time's up now i let
time run over
i give more i do more
giving more and doing more than is
required of you will make you destined
for success but do it because you love
it not because you think oh
need to stay at the office late i need
to spend more time with this customer
they don't really deserve it but i've
got to give give give it's not that kind
of giving but when you give more and do
more remember you
they remember you and they want to give
more back to you wanna be happy build a
life not just a business hey it's evan
carmichael and this channel was created
to help you overcome the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how you can manifest your
goals for this year
enjoy
rule number two change your thinking
with tom bilyeu as albert einstein said
the world as we have created it is a
process of our thinking it cannot be
changed without changing our thinking
the world that we're all living in is
our own construction and i think that's
the thing that people are missing we
have literally created this world and if
this world is delusion if this world is
destruction if this world is filled with
more bad than it is good
then that is a process of our thinking
that is a revelation
of how our minds work it is a revelation
of what we have built internally
so as leo tolstoy said everyone thinks
of changing the world but no one thinks
of changing themselves if we're actually
going to make change in the world if
those things you have in your mind the
vision of what you want to bring to the
world all of the ills that you want to
correct if you're actually going to
correct them
you have to look inward and begin asking
how is this your responsibility what are
the things in your thinking
that have helped manifest this world
that have manifested the problems in
your own life and that will my friends i
promise you
manifest the solutions
and as stephen hawking pointed out
the greatest enemy of knowledge is not
ignorance
it's the illusion of knowledge
we think we know something that we don't
we think we have the answers we think
within us already right now or the
fundamental building blocks that we're
going to need in order to build
something new but the truth is
the only thing that we already have is
the willingness to look
the willingness to change to leverage
the things that we have but we have to
build something entirely new we have to
understand that we don't yet know enough
that we are not adequate that we have to
look at ourselves and be willing to
stare nakedly at our inadequacies and to
adjust them to fix them to not hide
behind ego to not pretend or worse
believe
[Music]
that we're already who we need to be
because the only promise i can make you
is you're not yet the person you need to
be to execute to create the change that
you want to make
but i can also promise you
that you can become that if you're
willing to do the hard work of looking
internally and building something new if
you're willing to tear yourself down if
you're willing to brick by brick
disassemble that thing that has been
built by accident inside of you and move
forward with a new level of intention
and build something an entirely new
structure with your eyes open with
embracing and accepting
a lack of knowledge but never ignorance
of not
holding on to old ideas but to ask of
everything that you choose to believe
does this move me towards my goals or
not and if it does then you do it if it
does you believe it even more but if it
doesn't
right then right there you drop it
then you make room for the new
then you can build what you want to
build then
we'll have the change that we want rule
number three be passionate with lewis
howes energy is everything when you're
thinking about a law of attraction and
you need to be coming from a positive
grateful abundant
feeling
in order to start creating more of that
you can't come from a feeling of lack of
scarcity of not enough i don't love
myself if you don't love yourself you're
saying to the world to the universe to
other people
why would i work with you why don't i
connect with you why do i want to be in
love with you if you don't love yourself
so you've got to start shifting that way
of thinking the way of feeling the way
of being in order to really show up
energetically around other people one of
my early mentors told me the world makes
room for passionate people
think about it
if you are slunched over every single
day like this lacking confidence
stressed anxious
you know depressed and you're unable to
get out of your own way because you're
constantly thinking
about how much you don't love yourself
i've been there i know this feeling if
you're in that state
people aren't attracted to that they're
attracted to someone who is humble yet
confident at the same time in their
abilities
someone who cares and can look other
people in the eye someone who's got a
big heart and opens up and is willing to
receive information not someone who's
slouched over and has
you know a middle finger up to the world
they want people who are open who are
willing who are down to try things who
are passionate at least passionate about
the thing they care about and when you
show your passion about something
people are attracted to energy that is
passionate that is grateful that is fun
that is loving that is expressive that
is creative
that is
expansive they're not attracted to
people who are closed off and guarded
that is not attractive that is not sexy
in any part of life in relationship
health business you're not going to
attract people from that place so we're
working to reprogram your mind and break
the patterns that have been leading your
life because
i've been there in so many different
areas of my life for many different
years that have held me back and some
i've been confident in certain areas and
others i've lacked confidence and this
is a process and this is a journey and
it's not going to happen overnight
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four let go of doubt i
just want you to know doubt this comes
from the mind
and they're just thoughts and
and they're the reason that they're
appearing is because you have a belief
that is saying that you don't have this
already but just don't give those doubts
any any energy and work harder on
feeling that you have your manifestation
because when you believe you have your
manifestation no thoughts of doubt will
come
when you believe you have it you have
overridden any other belief in the
subconscious mind you've reprogrammed
your subconscious and then it will
manifest so
just remind yourself that you are the
power
that creates everything
effortlessly effortlessly
you are that power so so just
take it it's not it's not an effort it's
really easy
you know it's it's really easy just take
it easy
let go of the let go of the doubtful
thoughts rule number five believe with
bob proctor the law of vibration
do you know the secret
talked about the law of attraction
the secret was a runaway it went viral a
very best seller
it's reported a half a billion people
have been impacted by the movie or the
book the secret
now
i was very fortunate to have a key slot
in that movie
uh it's been often said that i'm better
known in iraq than i am in indiana
and uh i think that's true
this is the primary law right here
the law of attraction starts with the
law of vibration
and let's take a look
at where the law of vibration starts
it starts right in your own mind
right in your own head
your mind activates brain cells
and when those brain cells are activated
you're impacted you impact the whole
universe
do you know that
thought waves are cosmic waves that
penetrate all time in space you see as
you get studying this and as you start
to get into it in some depth
the ideas are so vast they're so huge
and you think this is about me
see i don't think
the vast majority of us
have ever been introduced to who we
really are
i think that
if a person started to show some promise
in developing a healthy self-image they
were
told that they were being conceited
don't be like that that's not the way it
should be
and of course we get a lot of other bad
information in there
but this law of vibration starts in our
own marvelous mind
and
i'd recommend that you start
really studying this
if you just stick with us
i what i've done i've taken some of the
most complicated material
and i've reduced it to the most
simplistic form
because that was the only way i was
going to understand it and i had
marvelous teachers that helped me get
that
now
lincoln said something absolutely
incredible lincoln said many things that
are incredible but he said to believe in
the things you can see and touch is no
belief at all
but i believe in the unseen
is a triumph and a blessing
think of
that
to believe in the things you can see and
touch we've got things we can see and
touch
that's no belief at all to believe in
the unseen is a triumph and a blessing
do you know the biggest part of you
you'll never see the real you you'll
never see
now we've got to start to
we're going to start to understand this
we've got to start to get it in the
right slot in our mind
we've got to realize that
there's so much to us
that we don't we don't really get we
don't understand
our educational system is so lacking in
teaching us who we are you can study
psychology but
most people that study psychology you've
never really got to know themselves
i'm talking about in depth who you
really are your relationship to the
whole scheme of thing or your
relationship to god you're talking about
an infinite power and you're created in
that image we have infinite potential
locked up within us
what we want to do is learn how to use
it for good in our life rule number six
be in resonance with john assaraf when
we're talking about energy there's the
great law of attraction of vibration
when things are on the same frequency
there are in resonance all right so
let's not think of the law of attraction
okay
as this thing that's like a magnet that
attracts because
if you were to take magnets and put
together you know positive and positive
it actually will repel it's positive and
negative that are in resonance and
attract
so when we're thinking about the law of
attraction i want you to skip the old
metaphysical laws that you may have
heard of or explanations you heard of
and i want you to think about resonance
so for example if you ever walked into a
room
and not a word has been said and you
know something's wrong and you say
because you're feeling
the vibration you're feeling this
something is wrong your intuition is
picking up the vibration in the room and
you know something's wrong and you go
hey what's wrong and the people in the
room go oh nothing
and you go no no seriously what's wrong
well how do you know that something is
off
and the answer is because this thing
called our body and this thing called
our brain is
and is energy vibrating at a certain
frequency and so when things are not
great we're emitting this frequency that
other
humans can feel we're picking it up with
our intuitive sensors in our brain
and through our field so when we think
about the law of attraction
we should actually be thinking about
am i in resonance right okay
energy that is on the same frequency
will resonate and attract so if you want
to understand the law of attraction
around wealth a relationship health
money are you in resonance
with that which is already here
see if you're thinking positive
but you're feeling negative if you're
thinking uh you know i want to double
triple quintuple my income but inside of
you you're thinking that you're not
smart enough not good enough not not
worthy enough then part of you is
vibrating at the here's what i want to
have be attract etc but if there's
another part of you vibrating at a
different frequency there is no harmony
there is no resonance there's chaos and
rule number seven the last one before
some very special bonus clips is feel
the fullness of life with eckhart tolle
let's say you want to
have an
uh
a nice house it's just
if i had a nice house
in the out in nature then i would be
really happy
i want to have a nice a nice house or in
nature next to a little forest
and then there's a lake there and i can
walk to the lake
and then how would you feel
okay
i would feel
exactly the way i'm feeling now
i want to live in hawaii and then i've
decked out to have a deck behind my
house with a very comfortable chair and
then i would sit in there every day and
contemplate the ocean
well good luck
how would you feel
what would you feel
i would feel the fullness of life
okay
and you can't feel it now
no why can't you feel it now
because i'm not sitting in this deck
chair
and i'm not looking at the ocean
and it's not sunny
that's why i can't feel the full and i
don't have a house behind me that i say
is mine
so i can't feel the fullness of life now
[Music]
okay then do you think you're going to
feel it when you finally sit in that
action no if you can't feel it now you
can't feel it then
because you will be again dissatisfied
in your deck chair behind the house
because you will get very bored
and stunned by mosquitoes
and it's too hot anyway i should have
gotten the house higher up
because
down here by the beach it's just too hot
why didn't i get a house bit higher up
because there's a mountain just behind
me it would be cooler
when you sell your house
get one higher up but then the nights
are too cold you can't sit outside
anymore
[Laughter]
if you're not
if you cannot feel the fullness of life
on your bicycle
and enjoy that moment tremendously of
being on your bicycle
[Music]
you will not feel the fullness of life
when you're sitting in your rolls-royce
or bentley or ferrari test test serum
test tester rosa
there's an overvaluing of things around
you
that i need
things to be in a certain way around me
to be happy and content
that doesn't mean that you cannot change
the environment around you you can take
steps towards changing it
because
you may have certain preferences
that's fine everybody has a preferences
the preference there's some spiritual
teachers who say oh i don't know i can't
remember but there are some who say
i have no preference
well
they live somewhere but not somewhere
else
so he must have a preference for being
there
unless somebody picks them up and puts
them somewhere
so you can you can have a preference for
living here rather than there
yes this country rather than that
country
[Music]
but while you're not there
you can
be in touch with the fullness of life
within yourself now
and then it's much more likely that your
external surroundings will reflect your
state of consciousness
most people never manifest their ideas
because you don't trust your ideas that
bold idea that came to you that made
sense to you in the moment the next day
feels too bold too crazy too insane two
not for someone like you i believe that
the decisions that come to you when
you're feeling bold are actually the
right ones for you and you have to take
immediate action on because otherwise
your head gets in the way and talks you
down from doing the things that you
should be doing so right now i'm in the
process of looking for a creative
director for my business someone to look
at all my content suggest ways to make
it better to to
be focused on the branding and
opportunities for me
and this was a suggestion from mark
drager friend of the channel a long time
personal friend of mine as well he
helped film my very first video he's the
reason why i did top 10 moves to success
long story with mark and he said evan
you need a creative director for your
business creative director or a brand
manager or ceo somebody to be in charge
of all the creative decisions and
getting me out on the stages that they
need to be out on
so how do we make these videos better
that's that person's role and so in my
head
when he first said it i'm i'm a little
afraid i'm scared like
how do i find this person i need to vibe
well with them i don't i can't just
bring anybody into that role i'm a
pretty weird duck and so this has to be
a good you know long-term fit for me how
much is this person going to cost how do
i fit into my cost structure right now
with my business how are we going to
deal with conflicts it's all of the
negativity all of the things that
are reasons why it's not going to work
and so in setting to focus on this is a
bold idea and i need to at least explore
it i need to try it i need to play it
out maybe it works maybe it doesn't but
teaching yourself teaching myself that i
do bold things i do scary things i do
difficult things and being scared is not
a good enough reason for not to take
action and so those ideas that come to
you trust that they came to you for a
reason
if it came to you and you're thinking
about it and you feel both like man i
would love to go off and do that the
best thing you can do is just start
going off and doing that
because what's going to happen is you're
going to plan plan plan plan plan you're
going to spend all your best energies
just stuck in planning mode instead of
actually going up and taking action
you're going to tell your friends about
it they're going to tell you it's a
stupid idea you're going to sleep on it
you're going to wake up and tell
yourself it's a stupid idea and then
what happens is no momentum the biggest
thing that is missing from your life
is momentum
nina's happy and is smiling she's next
to me filming that's always missing
you're a genius you have great ideas
great genius amazing ideas you're just
missing momentum
because once you get the idea you sit on
it and then you tell yourself why you
can't do it instead of going off and
proving to yourself that you can so how
do you find the ideas and then how do
you take action on them i'm going to
give you a three-step process step
number one is go for a walk have a
shower do whatever the thing is that
makes you feel
energized creative and in the zone right
if you're constantly just in front of
your phone and stressed out all day long
you're not going to come up with
creative ideas so where do you get
creative ideas i get creative ideas when
i'm driving i get creative ideas when
i'm in the shower i get creative ideas
when i'm walking i don't really meditate
so i don't get ideas when i'm doing that
but it's it's time when there's nothing
scheduled
and so do you have enough time during
your week or during your day that is
open that you allow yourself to think
and be creative
for a lot of people watching this you
probably do you probably have some
moments in your calendar that are
dedicated to at least having a shower
hopefully hopefully you have showers on
a regular basis right so you're coming
up with ideas right so whatever that
thing is that lets you come with ideas
do more of it right if you get great
ideas in the shower
maybe instead of a five-minute shower
take a 15-minute shower maybe you get
some more ideas coming to you right you
want to you want to spend more time
doing the work that generates creativity
for you that's step number one step
number two is don't judge the ideas that
come to you this is where so many people
fall down you get an idea and then you
judge it and you say i can't do that i'm
not good enough i don't have the money i
know the connections i didn't go to
school for that i'm not tall enough i'm
not pretty enough i'm not smart enough
whatever people like me don't do this
thing all these ideas why you can't win
you're telling yourself why you can't
win before you even started
don't judge the idea trust that the idea
came to you for a reason so if i'm
thinking about somebody
in the shower somebody that maybe i met
yesterday or somebody that i haven't
talked to in three years
why am i thinking about that person um i
don't know
italians have this expression they go
book means i don't know
so i trust that idea came for a reason
that idea is flowing through me for a
reason and i gotta do something about it
and so whenever i'm thinking about
somebody in the shower the next thing is
i get out of the shower and i'll email
that person right away and i'll always
make it awkward and say hey i was
thinking about you in the shower today
and then tell them what the story was
and it's never backfired on me
it's never backfired on me sometimes it
leads to some great opportunity and
sometimes it goes nowhere but you get
the idea you do something get the idea
you do something stop judging the idea
stop telling yourself why you can't do
it and then step number three is take
immediate action and build momentum
again the biggest thing that you're just
missing is momentum you're a genius
you're an amazing entrepreneur you've
got tons of potential sarah blakely had
this idea to create spanx and it made
her billionaire when everybody thought
she was crazy right i'm sure you have
ideas like that too what's the
difference between you and her momentum
she did more she started she took the
nose she took the rejection she took the
fears and she said i'm gonna give it my
shot
you need to build immediate momentum as
soon as you get that idea whether it's
in the shower on the walk on the drive
whatever it is as soon as you get that
it you're not allowed to leave that
moment that moment of courage and money
of boldness that moment of feeling
unstoppable that moment of like i can do
this when you're feeling that moment
you're not allowed to leave it without
having done something immediate action
every single time and sometimes that
leads to something great and maybe the
momentum falls off the next day that's
okay but in the moment
you have to take immediate action no
more excuses stop letting yourself off
the hook stop telling yourself that you
suck and you can't do it and go show
yourself that you can the thing that we
often forget is that we're all miracle
workers wherever we are
you're not just a miracle worker
or if you want to call it a light worker
or whatever you want to call it
if you're working as a life coach or
you're a therapist or you're
a speaker or writer or whatever it is
you're every where we go is a moment to
offer someone a shift in their
perception which is a miracle everywhere
we go is a moment to
help transcend the limitations of the
world and be a force of good in the
presence of another human
so
start now
where you are
and then let the universe show you what
to do
because
we start to get into how do i get there
what am i going to do
the overthinking and the plotting and
the scheming
gets in the way of the allowing
so be in the work do the work in every
encounter
at the grocery store
at the doctor's office at your job on
the zoom
be the light wherever you go
excellent
so you're already doing it you got your
yoga classes
keep doing what you're doing keep
bringing that light with you wherever
you go and i guarantee you
the universe will reveal to you the next
action and the next action and the next
action so i actually don't want you to
try to figure it out i want you to stay
in the momentum of what you've already
created which is that you're bringing it
to the yoga class you're bringing it to
the office you're bringing it to the
home you're bringing it to your
friendships
it will be revealed to you i guarantee
you
that's the whole point that's the whole
point
there's a lot of practical things that
you could you could do if you're like i
want to go build a business whatever
sure there's a million ways you could do
that but i
i think right now is your moment by the
way one of my signs was a check mark and
somebody just put a check mark in the
thank you for my sign thank you thank
you thank you out there for the check
mark okay so i um
baby baby baby
i believe you
i feel you i trust you that you are here
to bring a lot of love and to teach in
your own unique way
i don't want you to overthink it i don't
want you to get in the way of it i don't
want you to start too soon in the sense
of leaving your job or whatever i want
you
to be
in the daily devotion of how can i serve
in every corner of your life and get
that fully and completely and that's
when there's more check marks and that's
when you are going to be very very very
clear about what the next right action
is for you i mean it i really mean it i
think that when we're trying to bring a
new energy into the work that we do or
into our relationships or anything in
our life if we get too
heady about it and too logical about it
and too detailed about it at first
we actually get in the way of what it
can be
the details and the logic and all that
can come but i want you to right now in
this moment be super grounded in
how can i serve at my yoga class more
how can i serve in this existing job
more and as you start to do that you'll
be very very it'll be very clear to you
and revealed to you have you ever seen a
mustard seed here i have some here
i want to pull one out now jesus said if
you had the faith of a mustard seed you
could move mountains
and anything was possible now i heard
this as a kid and i really believed it
and so the question is what do you
believe
do you believe that you are worthy
of happiness do you believe that
happiness
success
abundance
comfort fulfillment peace
joy
love
is a part of your birthright
is that what you believe
or do you believe something else because
you will
manifest
the life that you believe the universe
in some way is kind of a little bit
rigged against us that's correct let me
prove to you
here's a garden now when you plant roses
what do you get
what do you get
comment below you get roses right
now what happens if you don't plan
anything and you don't take time to even
take care of the garden you don't even
pay attention to it what happens
weeds grow
so it is not the case that if you
don't plant something nothing will
happen no it's rather the case when you
don't plan anything
weeds grow and that's how our mind works
so if you're not constantly feeding your
mind i call that mind feed if you don't
constantly feed your mind with
positive motivation inspiration
something
something that moves you towards your
goals practical useful
information to feed your mind if you're
not doing that constantly weeds grow and
that's why personally i don't watch news
because most news are nothing more than
negativity and they are just
designed to grab your attention right
the design is just sensations it doesn't
actually do much to your life it doesn't
add value to your life it doesn't make
you a better person except it scares the
heck out of you you watch enough news
you don't even want to go out right you
don't want to do anything so i don't
watch news if it's important enough
guess what my team someone would tell me
i'll eventually find out but most of the
time i don't know what is going on i
focus on what i do i want to protect
this
i want to protect my filter
i'm very very careful about
how i view the world and how i upgrade
my filter and that's why law of
attraction it works all the time it
works 24 7. you cannot stop it even if
you want to you cannot stop it even if
you're not paying attention to it so you
could choose
you can choose what information you
consume every single day you can choose
what you pay attention to you can choose
what channel you watch you can choose
what videos you watch you have the power
to choose visualization is one of the
great secrets of success that's where we
build a picture in our mind
when van gogh was asked how do you do
such beautiful work he said i dream my
painting and then i paint my dream
well that's the way it works
and all the great leaders have been
great visionaries
and
solomon said where there is no vision
the people will perish now that doesn't
mean they're going to die it just
means their results are going to get
weaker and weaker and weaker and they're
just not going to be making it happen
the way they want to
everyone visualizes whether he realizes
it or not
visualization is a great secret to
success now look at this
the conscious use of this great power
attracts attracts to you
multiplied resources
multiply it attracts to you
you know something about the law of
attraction how do we attract
well through visualization
now look it
and it intensifies your wisdom
and enables you to make use of
advantages you formally fail to
recognize if you organize your mind
to a certain level of organization
it in turn organizes the whole system
your body your emotion your energies
everything gets organized in the
direction
once all these four dimensions of you
your physical body
your mind your emotion and
the fundamental life energies are
organized in one direction
once you are like this
anything that you wish happens without
even lifting a little finger actually it
would help to assist it with activity
but
even without doing any activity you can
still manifest what you want if you
organize these four dimensions
in one direction and keep it unwavering
in that direction for a certain period
of time
right now the problem with your mind is
every moment it is changing its
direction
it is like you want to travel somewhere
and every two steps if you keep changing
your direction the question of you
reaching the destination is very remote
unless it happens by chance once we're
empowered like this it's very important
that our physical action
emotional action
mental action and energy actions are
controlled and properly directed
if it is not so we become destructive
self-destructive
right now that is our problem the
technology which is supposed to make our
life beautiful and easy has become the
source of all the problem that we are
destroying the very basis of our life
which is the planet
so what should have been a boon we are
making a curse out of it
what has brought incredible
levels of comfort and convenience to us
in the last
100 years or so
has also become a threat to our life
simply because
we are not
conscious action we are in a compulsive
state of action
so organizing our minds fundamentally
means
moving from
a compulsive state of activity to a
conscious state of activity how do you
feel after an interview
do you walk away and go like wow that
was really insightful i learned a lot
this is wonderful take that same feeling
and hold that feeling in your mind as
you repeat that affirmation with a
visualization okay
creates a pattern in your subconscious
that starts to vibrate
at that frequency and you might have
interviewed hundreds of people and
there's some interviews that you go like
oh that wasn't that great but there's
some that you go like this is probably
one of my best take the feeling from
your best interview and insert that into
your affirmation because now it's going
to be vibrating at that feeling and then
you'll start attracting anything of a
similar vibration to it immediately
trust your ideas believe that they're
amazing and and manifest them into the
world i love it i'm not taking it from
the approach of i want this book to be a
new york times bestseller and i'm
sitting there visualizing my book being
a new york times bestseller
i'm not visualizing myself being on
brendon burchard's stage in puerto rico
to a couple thousand people uh that's
not the process that i typically go
through although i'm open to that maybe
being a mistake i don't know
it's never really felt like
it's worth it i don't know i'm sitting
there i've done it many times sitting
there visualizing i've never really felt
like that made a difference
i'm open to being totally wrong
but how i do apply it and
massively seen an impact is as soon as i
get an idea for something it's it's go
time trust that vision that came to you
trust that idea that's in your head and
do something immediately about it when i
thought about the idea of of having a
house of building a custom home i then
went off and built a 5 000 square foot
custom home like inside of the year we
had the whole thing done
when i thought about
silly things like i thought about having
a mannequin i was watching green arrow
on tv
and i loved how they all had their their
mannequins when they were in their their
lair or their realm they had their
outfits their costumes on a mannequin
and i thought i feel like i'm i'm the
green arrow i'm i got the deep hood look
i could be this is this is the believe
arrow right
uh i want a mannequin too and then
inside of a week i had my own mannequin
here and so it may seem crazy mainstream
wild but that's how i tend to operate
and i think it's amazing
right now i'm thinking about doing a
30-day challenge on my youtube channel
my main youtube channel where every day
for the next 30 days i have a series of
videos to help you build a better life
so like 30 days to a better life
and it's going to be some of our best
work and i thought of the idea and now
immediately we're doing it and so
trusting the ideas that come to me and
then immediately creating them and i
guess manifesting them into the world i
am a thousand percent all in on
the
sitting and visualizing
the thing that i want i have a struggle
with and i'm open to um making it better
and and being changed i faced the
hardest time with this is my health so
i broke my neck last year right i wore
this for for
uh 60 days taking it off for 10 minutes
a day that was it and i had a concussion
and i had two spots in my neck that were
broken and i did some meditation with a
guy named michael edwards who
led me through this guided meditation
and he helped me and he was doing it
with me in person
over over the phone sending me videos
and
first off was getting the concussion
away because i'd never had a concussion
before and the meditation i found really
helped the concussion the second part
was the visualization so i have a bone
in the back of my neck that broke off
so the big bone broken is healed the
little bone just kind of broke off like
the tip like imagine i guess the
fingernail kind of hanging loose right
and it broke off and the doctor said
it's not going to come back together and
and it's not worth going and doing
surgery on it because it's not a big
deal don't worry about it
and michael was convinced that i could
heal myself and i could make that bone
come back together and so every
night and every morning i would do it
twice a day
meditating and visualizing the neck
coming back together and and you know
take some
you know hand sanitizer or not hand
sensitive take some lotion and and you
know put it on my neck and just as i'm
to get more tactical like as i'm doing
it the the bones connecting i talked to
john assaraf who is a another you know
legendary expert in his field and he's
peacefully convinced that it can come
back together through visualization
through meditation i haven't done it yet
i haven't i haven't i haven't cracked
the code on how to do it i wish i did we
did x-rays
uh 60 days later and it's still just as
disconnected it still just didn't move
a centimeter a millimeter closer
and that was honestly a little bit
uh you know negative or low or defeating
and and my motivation to do it as
intensely has
has waned i haven't been doing it twice
a day every day
i still
want to believe that as possible and i
still
kind of believe that it's possible and
maybe that's not enough maybe that's the
problem uh maybe the problem was i never
believed enough that it could happen and
that's why it didn't happen so i would i
would love for that to work i would love
for meditation to work i've meditated
with
i don't know how many different people
so many different people i've never
really felt the benefit
[Music]
of having a meditation just feels
like i'm like i'm sitting down nothing
wrong with it just i don't feel extra
clarity or anything coming out of the
meditation so
i believe that it has worked for other
people i believe that it can work for me
i haven't found the path to make it work
so that's where i'm still struggling and
trying to improve and trying to get
better and reaching out to experts and
why i still feature people on my channel
because i'm trying to learn through the
process as well but but the idea of
taking the ideas that do come to you and
taking immediate action on them right
the last letters of of law of attraction
is action doing something trusting them
i think a thousand percent that can
serve you it has served me i know for
sure can serve you to learn to trust
your ideas and do something immediately
today about it and then build momentum
towards it and that big crazy thing that
you have in your mind may not even be
that big and crazy once you actually
start taking some action on it and so
that part i'm a thousand percent down on
and you need to do something today in
your life to change
and the other side i'm totally open to
feedback suggestions on how
i can get better how you can get better
in my latest book the greatest secret
the most important practice in that book
without a doubt is welcoming negative
emotions because
when you welcome any negative emotion
you are dissolving it from within your
body from within the subconscious mind
the next time say for example if it was
anger the next time you feel anger it's
not nearly as bad you welcome again
the time after that it's reducing
reducing until
it's not possible for you to feel anger
anymore
and with that anger gone from your body
your body the health of your body is
working brilliantly
but two you will just manifest like you
can't believe like just a single little
flimsy thought and it will manifest
so
getting rid of negative emotions also
negative emotions are covering over your
basic nature which is happiness and all
of this i explain
in the greatest secret i explain it all
in here
um and so
yeah it's your it's your basic nature so
negative emotions are covering up your
happiness so to get rid of those
emotions is really really important so
now i wanted to explain that to
everybody who doesn't know about the
welcoming process
and now let me explain the welcoming
process to you what we tend to do with
negative emotions is we tend to resist
them so don't feel good right
and so we want to push them away we
don't want to feel that we don't want to
feel fear we don't want to feel
disappointment impatience and anger and
so we'll push them away we think we're
pushing them away but in actual fact
we're pushing them down
here into our body into the subconscious
mind and they act like a pressure cooker
they're causing harm to the body but
they also act like a pressure cooker
in that they need to release some energy
to so that because they're just about to
burst and so they'll find something in
the world an emotion will find something
in the world to get angry about to
release the pressure in your body and so
welcoming
is the opposite to resisting you're
pushing them away now you're not going
to do that now you're going to welcome
the negative emotion so when a negative
emotion arises basically what you're
going to do is kind of do nothing you
know really
um welcoming is just stopping us from
resisting what i do
is i imagine that that emotion is a
really really good friend of mine
and i'm just allowing it to be here i'm
allowing it to be here in the body and i
just imagine that it's a friend and i
put my arms around it and as you welcome
it or allow it to be here
something absolutely incredible happens
it just dissolves
it just dissolves
and in that moment you have managed to
get rid of a whole lot of that negative
emotion in your body and so that's why
this is the most incredible process
because a you will get happier and
happier b every desire you've ever
wanted will be fulfilled
and say you will have the most
incredible life a life free of fear
and um
and knowing who you are and
understanding the incredible power
you have in the world so just imagine
that
you have a friend and you're putting
your arms around a friend that is how i
do it but also too
something you can do is i'll just make
sure you can see my arms
what you can do is just open your arms
up like this because opening your arms
like this
sort of opens the whole chest area
and that automatically
makes you stop resisting right and you
open like this and you will feel that
negative emotion
dissolve you can't feel the emotion of
your future
your manifestation of love before it's
made manifest like people say well well
my relationship happen when i find mr
right then i'm going to feel love
waiting for the outer environment to
change
to take away this feeling of anger
resentment emptiness
but they forgot that they create reality
in other words when it finally appears
that i'm going to feel love that's
that's cause and effect we're waiting
for something to happen if you're
feeling the lack and the emptiness
then you're keeping your relationship at
arm's length because you don't have the
magnetic field to draw to you so
the emotions that come from these energy
centers the lower energy centers in our
body do have frequencies there's
chemistry involved
but they have a different agenda
so now we ask the person
can you teach
your body emotionally
what the future will feel like before
it's made manifest that means you can't
wait for your relationship to feel love
you have to reverse that battleship and
understand feeling love now is going to
be the magnet and if you can hold the
vision of your future a clear intention
with a coherent brain
organize signals into the field and you
could actually crack this thing open
and
practice
getting so present in the moment
that you're not anticipating the next
moment or trying to predict the future
and you're no longer romancing the
emotions of your past
you can find that sweet spot of the
generous present moment the familiar
past is the known emotionally the
predictable future is the habituation of
autopilot being unconscious in programs
those are both knowns there's only one
place where the unknown exists that's
the present moment so if you could work
with your body
to the point that it trusts you enough
to feel so safe
that you have conquered it in a certain
way that it could actually relax into
the present moment and it's not worried
about what's going to happen next or
what's going on around around you or
that you need to eat you need to pee you
need to move you you got beyond all your
drives and you're you're ready to create
that moment where you're present
if you could begin to work with your
heart
and start to breathe and start to
practice feeling love in the beginning
it would feel foolish or gratitude why
would i feel love if it hasn't happened
well that's because you've been
hypnotized into waiting for your world
to change to feel feel the emotion from
the experience
but according to the quantum model
your emotion ahead of the experience
when you combine that clear intention
with the elevated emotion
and you feel love your body's so
objective
that it's actually believing it's living
in that future
in the present moment and your body now
is beginning to change
you are beginning to change your biology
to reflect
what you're about to experience in your
future
so the stronger the
love you feel the more altered you feel
inside of you the more you're going to
pay attention to that picture in your
mind stimulus response memory emotion
thought and feeling but now you're
remembering your future
instead of remembering your past if
you're truly in the present moment and
you know exactly what you want
and you
begin to teach your body emotion start
practicing opening that heart it's
amazing what happens
the moment that heart begins to open
we've measured this so many times lewis
on a scan on a real-time brain scan
when the heart moves into this kind of
rhythm when you're feeling
frustration
when you're feeling impatient when
you're feeling resentment you are
stepping on the gas pedal and you're
stepping on the brake at the same time
and the heart is pumping against the
closed system and it causes an erratic
beat it becomes incoherent and energy
literally leaves the heart now you no
longer believe in your future you can't
put your heart into your future you
can't trust the outcome because there's
no energy there it's it's being used and
consumed somewhere else so energy is
leaving the brain as well
but once energy starts to move into the
heart we've seen this so many times and
it starts to beat in this rhythm like
banging a drum or dropping a pebble in
water pebble after pebble the heart
begins to create a wave of energy right
to the brain like like taking a big
sheet
and going like that and then all of a
sudden you see this wave and the brain
gets this rush of energy and that change
in brain wave patterns that change that
wave is carrying information
and the person starts to get a very
clear idea they see their future very
clearly now now that energy is causing
them to move into very coherent alpha
brainwave patterns which is the state of
creation this is when you no longer hear
the voice in your head that's talking to
you that you listen to and believe is
the truth i'm not good enough yeah
whatever that is
that's called the default mode it
suppresses the default mode network and
the next thing you know
you start seeing in pictures and images
you start dreaming
and that's the imagination that's the
creative state so now you start
naturally imagining the heart is the
creative center we got to put our heart
into our future it better be open and
activated
so now when you start falling in love
with your future
oxytocin is released in the brain and in
the heart
oxytocin signals nitric oxide nitric
oxide signals another chemical called
endothelial derived relaxing factor and
just like when your sexual organs get
filled with blood because you're aroused
the same thing happens here as it would
happen somewhere else and literally the
arteries in the heart and lungs engorge
and now your heart feels full and it's
thumping in order and you're
in the present moment now once that
happens
and it's beating in rhythm the heart
produces an external magnetic field up
to three meters wide now
you're in survival you're drawing from
the field and turning into chemistry
when you get energy in the heart it's
causing a change in the brain and all of
a sudden it's resetting the baseline for
trauma
and now here you have a magnetic field
now the heart
is your magnet it is it is the center of
creation and now that that energy is
frequency
and frequency carries information and
you can lay the thought of your new
relationship life is a series of changes
those of us who are rigid and inflexible
in our thinking often snap when the
winds of change blow
but those of us who are like willow
trees
bend easily and adapt to the new changes
if we refuse to change then life passes
us by and we get left behind
just as a flexible body is more
comfortable to be in
so is a flexible mind more comfortable
to live in
i am open to the new and changing
every moment presents a wonderful new
opportunity to become more of who i am
i flow with life easily and effortlessly
[Music]
i now go beyond other people's fears and
limitations
i am not my mother's fears and
limitations nor am i my father's fears
and limitations i'm not even my own
fears and limitations these are only
false thoughts that have been hanging
around in my mind
i can erase them as easily as i can
clean a dirty window when the window of
my mind is clean i can see clearly the
negative thoughts for what they are and
i can choose to eliminate them
it is my mind that creates my
experiences
i am unlimited in my own ability to
create the good in my life
life mirrors my every thought
as i keep my thoughts positive life
brings me only good experiences
there is plenty for everyone including
me
there is so much food on this planet
that we could feed everyone
yes there are people who are starving
but it is not the lack of food it is the
lack of love that allows this to happen
there was so much money and so many
riches in the world far more than we
know
if it were all distributed equally
within a month or so those who have
money now would have more and those who
are poor now would once again be poor
for wealth has to do with consciousness
and deservability
there are billions of people on this
planet yet you will hear people tell you
that they are lonely
if we don't reach out love cannot find
us
so as i affirm my self-worth and my
deservability that which i need comes to
me in the perfect time space
availability
the ocean of life is lavish with its
abundance
all my needs and desires are met before
i even ask
my good comes from everywhere and
everyone and everything
all is well in my world
my life has always worked perfectly only
i did not know it i didn't realize that
every negative event in my world was
life reflecting back to me my belief
system
now that i am aware i can consciously
program my thinking process to have a
life that works on all levels
everything in my life works now and
forevermore
my work is deeply fulfilling
when we learn to love what we do then
life sees to it that we will always have
interesting creative occupations
when you are ready emotionally and
mentally for the next step in life life
will move you to it
give your best to life today
i do what i love and love what i do i
know that i am always working in the
right place with just the right people
and that i learn all of the valuable
lessons my soul needs to learn
life supports me
when you follow the laws of life life
will support you abundantly
life created me to be fulfilled i trust
life and life is always there at every
turn i am safe
my future is glorious
our futures will always represent our
current thoughts
what you are thinking and saying right
now is creating your future so think
glorious thoughts and you will have a
glorious future
i now live in limitless love light and
joy
all is well in my
world i open new doors to life
as i walk down the corridor of life
there are doors on every side each one
opens to a new experience
the more i clear the negative thought
patterns from my mind the more i find
doors that open to only good experiences
my clarity of thinking brings to me the
best that life has to offer
i rejoice in what i have
and i know fresh new experiences are
always ahead of me i greet the new with
open arms i trust life to be wonderful
i claim my own power and i lovingly
create my own reality
no one can do it for you
only you can make your own declarations
in your mind
if you give your power to others then
you have none when you claim your power
it is yours use it wisely
i ask for more understanding so that i
may knowingly and lovingly shape my
world and my experiences
i now create a wonderful new job
bless your current job with love and
release it with love to the next person
who takes your place
knowing that you are moving into a new
level of life
keep your affirmations for the new
position clear and positive and know
that you deserve the best
i am totally open and receptive to a
wonderful new position
using my creative talents and abilities
working with and for people i love in a
wonderful location and earning good
money
everything i touch is a success
we always have the option of poverty
thinking or prosperity thinking
when we think thoughts of lack and
limitation then that is what we
experience
there is no way you can be prosperous if
your thinking is impoverished
to be successful you need to constantly
think thoughts of prosperity and
abundance
i now establish a new awareness of
success
i know i can be as successful as i make
my mind up to be
i move into the winning circle
golden opportunities are everywhere for
me prosperity of every kind is drawn to
me
i am open and receptive to new avenues
of income
when we are open and receptive life will
find many ways to bring income to us as
we know and affirm that we deserve all
good the infinite source will open new
channels
we often limit our own good by believing
in fixed income and other closed ideas
opening our consciousness opens the
banks of heaven
i now receive my good from expected and
unexpected sources
i am an unlimited being accepting from
an unlimited source in an unlimited way
i am blessed beyond my fondest dreams
i deserve the best and i accept the best
now
the only thing that keeps us from having
the good in our life is that we don't
believe we deserve it
somewhere in childhood we learned that
we didn't deserve and we believed it now
it is time to release that belief
i am mentally and emotionally equipped
to enjoy a prosperous and loving life it
is my birthright to deserve all good i
claim my good now
life is simple and easy
the laws of life are simple far too
simple for many people who want to
struggle and complicate things what you
give out comes back to you what you
believe about yourself and about life
becomes true for you
it is that simple
all i need to know at any given moment
is revealed to me i trust myself and i
trust life and all is well trying to get
them to focus upon
positive things and we sort of laid out
a list of positive things that she might
think about and she said oh abraham i
don't want those i've already got those
and what she really meant was
the things that i want are the things
that have not yet happened and we want
to help you to realize that if you're
thinking about things that you want from
the standpoint that they have not yet
come to fruition that they are still
missing in your experience
then you're holding it in a sort of
suspended position where the distance
between where you are and where it is is
not closing
so what we're wanting you to realize is
you have these patterns of thought
and law of attraction is helping you to
sustain the pattern of thought that you
have a belief is just a thought you keep
thinking and so early on in your
experience by your exposure to life you
began developing some patterns of
thought sometimes they were carefully
taught to you by others
sometimes it came because of something
that you observed and then talked about
and then remembered and then attracted
again and then talked about it and then
remembered and then attracted again in
other words life is very interesting
here isn't it because you can't talk
about anything for very long before it
begins to replicate itself in your life
experience and it's what makes you
develop your patterns of what you call
truths
you say
at first i wasn't sure
and then i pondered it for a while
and once i gave it my attention
i began seeing evidence of it everywhere
and now i believe it and now that i
believe it it's manifesting in my
experience and we say that's really
wonderful isn't it if it's stuff you
want
but if you are repeating patterns of
thought about things you do not want
and in your environment oh you are very
very good at that you have this
sort of mass consciousness theory that
goes like this
if we don't beat the drum of our history
we are sure to repeat it again and we
say the contrary is true
the more you beat the drum of anything
the more you activate it in your
vibration the more it is activated in
your vibration
then the more law of attraction is
matching you up with things like it and
the more law of attraction is matching
you up with things like it the more you
observe it and the more you observe it
the more you talk about it the more you
talk about it and observe it the more
you beat the drum of it or offer the
vibration of it the more you offer the
vibration of it the more law of
attraction matches you up with it the
more law of attraction matches you up
with it the more you're living it the
more you're talking about it the more
you're beating the drum of it the more
you're offering the vibration of it this
gathering we're calling it the art of
allowing but what it really means is the
art of telling a different story the art
of telling the story the way life has
helped you carve it out incrementally
but telling the story
with your words with your observations
with your expectations with your
vibration
then when law of attraction is
responding to your deliberate offering
of thought now you're getting what you
want not just what you're observing
are there things in your life that are
as you want them to be
keep telling that story
are the things in your life that are not
as you want it to be
don't tell that story
you cannot choose something that feels
better until you are aware of what you
are choosing
so
relief is the order of business what do
you want to talk about in 1925
physicists said that our vision of a
universe split into an invisible energy
realm and a material physical realm was
a total illusion
that everything is energy the whole
thing there is no matter in this world
and to summarize what the meaning was a
famous physicist in 1930 by the name of
sir james jeans
said we have been led to believe that
the universe is a great machine
when in fact it is more a great thought
and the reality about that was quantum
physicists have established since 1925
that consciousness is the primary
mechanism of creativity of the world
that we experience in fact a more recent
article in the journal nature which is
like
a
scientific mainstream journal was an
article by a quantum physicist at johns
hopkins university by the name of
richard conhenry
and his article was entitled the mental
universe
i i know the last two lines in the
article because they were like
so powerful and here's what the
conclusion of the article was
the universe is immaterial
it's mental and spiritual
live
and enjoy
and this is so exciting because science
is coming out saying it's mental and
spiritual it's like oh my god but that's
the quantum physics part
and the reality about it why is that and
so important as uh sad vijay had just
mentioned
it's our thoughts
that are manifesting this world now you
could say that's a spiritual thing and
now i say not only is it spiritual now
it is fundamental basic science of the
universe and it says then the thoughts
are creative well if the thoughts are
created then who is having the thought
and you start to realize i'm having the
thought well then the truth is simple as
richard khan henry said
you are creating this world with your
mental activity and your spirituality
combined and then all of a sudden it
says well then if i'm creating the world
then my original belief that when things
didn't go right i was a victim
the universe wasn't supporting me you
know it's like oh i try so hard and the
universe is not giving me things it
turns 180 degrees around
and it basically says this
we
are creating this world
and then i say your mind is creating
this world
and then i give you the science that
says there are two minds that are
operating at the same time one is called
the conscious mind and one is called the
subconscious mind i say what's the
difference
the conscious mind is where you are as a
spirit an entity a unique identity you
are
in that conscious mind and perceiving
the world i say what about the
subconscious mind it's not a creative
mind the subconscious mind is habits
things that you've learned and you
experienced in your life and they become
habits so
the subconscious mind is not thinking
creating a subconscious mind push the
button
play the behavior
so here's the point
when we are in our conscious mind we are
connecting our spirituality to the
biology and the physical planet that
we're in and that is a creative mind
that's the one you wake up in the
morning and say
oh i wish i had this and i desire that
and these are the things i want
and then you go out and start the day
and then guess what
95
of the day
you are not operating from the conscious
mind science is recognized 95 of the day
because we are thinking 95 of the day
our behavior is now controlled by the
subconscious mind
i go okay so what's the difference in
the final conclusion of this is
the conscious mind with your creativity
has your wishes and your desires
the subconscious mind was programmed by
other people
your mother your father your siblings
and your community so what is the
difference
you wake up with a wish and a desire of
what you want
and then the rest of the day
you play the programs that you got from
other people that don't answer your
wishes and don't support your desires
and all you see is the consequence of it
and go oh my god why is it not working
the answer is because you don't see
because remember the name is
subconscious below conscious
so when that behavior is playing
psychologists will tell us
70 percent or more
of the programs in the subconscious
are disempowering
self-sabotaging and limiting behaviors
so the simple reality is this
we have great wishes and desires and yet
our life is not controlled by that our
life is controlled by the programming
and that programming is the
disempowering program so all you see
is the consequence of the invisible
subconscious which will sabotage
all the desires and wishes you have and
then to conclude that what if you just
didn't
default to the subconscious what if you
just stayed in the conscious mind that's
called being mindful
and why is it relevant
because when you stay
conscious keep your mind present
you are the creator
of your life and when people are in
mindfulness they manifest their wishes
their desires and their happiness so for
all of us it's sort of a wake-up call
you think you're running your life with
your wishes and desires it's an illusion
you're really running your life with
your programs acquired from other people
i use a diagram to explain the mind now
let this circle represent your mind
and let this little circle here
represent your body
now i want you to think of this for a
moment
your body is a molecular structure this
is a massive energy and a very high
speed of vibration
if you looked at your body through a
microscope you'd see that energy dancing
right before your eyes and here's
something that'll keep you thinking for
the next 20 years when you move out of
it the body does not stop moving if you
go to a funeral parlor and pick up the
remains and look at it you will see it
moving and if it wasn't moving how would
it ever change the dust
you move into your body and you will
move up
and it's how you use your mind that's
going to dictate the vibration you're in
now stay with me
you have an imaginary line right across
here
and that separates the conscious mind
from the subconscious mind
now this subconscious mind has been
programmed
when you were a little baby this is the
way it was you're just like this
subconscious mind wide open and
everything that was going on around it
went right in there
and all the energy that went in there
when you were just a little baby formed
something called a paradigm
now a paradigm
is information it's a multitude of
habits you are the product of your
environment but prior to that you are
the product of a genetic strain that
goes back for generations now i'm going
to say that the paradigm is x type
energy
now you've got the ability here on a
conscious level to think
and you can think anything you want to
think
and as you think you build ideas
there's a power that's flowing into your
consciousness it never stops it flows to
and through you you can actually
photograph this power leaving you it
flows to and through you
now as it flows in you will start
thinking and you'll probably think
x-type thoughts
therefore you're going to be in an x
type vibration
and that will produce
x type results now it's the results you
want to change
and to change the results you're going
to have to change what you attract
you see the thoughts that you think
control the vibration that you're in
vibration is nothing but an idea it's a
law of the universe everything vibrates
nothing rests we live in a notion of
motion
and it's the thoughts that you're
thinking that you impress upon your
subconscious mind that control the
vibration the body's in and that
dictates how you act but it also
dictates what you attract
you attract energy that's in harmony
with you you attract people that are in
harmony with you you see everything
operates on frequencies there's an
infinite number of frequencies but you
and i operate on a frequency just like a
radio station does and the only music
you can attract is the music that is
tuned in to the vibration you're in
now it's the paradigm that has been
controlling the vibration
you can change your thinking
but that doesn't do anything you've got
to change the paradigm
and if you don't change the paradigm
nothing happens
now talking about paradigms is another
subject we'll do that at another time
but it's the thoughts that you think
that control the vibration you're in and
that dictates what you attract so if you
keep attracting what you don't want
understand this
it's the paradigm that's causing the
problem you can think a y type thought
which is totally different than the x
type conditioning it isn't going to go
anywhere
because when you go to get emotionally
involved and this is the emotional mind
when you go to get emotionally involved
with that y-type done the paradigm will
kick it out you know why it's so
uncomfortable
that's stepping out of the box that's
doing things different and we don't like
to do things different because it causes
a lot of discomfort
but understand this
the paradigm and the thinking control
the vibration you're in and the
vibration is going to dictate what you
attract
people that are in a poverty
consciousness will continue to attract
lack and limitation it has nothing to do
with this what's going on here this is
your educated mind and you can gather
all kinds of information have you ever
wondered why some people have such an
educated mind they have degrees coming
right off the end of their business card
but it doesn't show up in their results
why
paradigm
the law of attraction
you've got to change this
you've got to change the vibration
you're in and your whole world changes
listen
in 1961 a man gave me this book and he
said do exactly what i tell you he was
giving me y type ideas it caused an
enormous amount of discomfort but i did
exactly what he said and you know
something
my income went from 4 000 to 175 000 in
a year and then i took it over a million
it took me nine and a half years to
figure out what happened
this is what i'm showing you
watch this over and over and over again
there's a number of lessons in here
and another lesson i'm going to show you
how to change the paradigm when you
change the paradigm the change in
results is automatic you know why you
start to attract something new something
different and what we want to do
is program in positive information and
eliminate the negative i'm going to show
you how to do that
a law of attraction
you attract according to the vibration
you're in this thing we live in is a
molecular structure your body is a
massive energy you know if you put your
body in front of an infrared television
camera in a completely dark room your
whole being would be nothing but a
glistening radiating gleaming form
feeling is conscious awareness of the
vibration we're in when we don't feel
good
we're in a negative vibration
you want to feel good move into a
positive vibration stop and think of
what you're grateful for
but understand this
you will never attract to you
wealth happiness health until you get
the paradigm and get you on that
frequency that's bob procter thank you
tantra means the technology
technology means
when those times when we did not have
any external instruments of technology
we realize the highest grade of
technologies here
and to exercise this
in many different ways
now
if we want to see outside the door
we need a periscope
now somebody found a way to look beyond
without a periscope
using your mind
beyond the realm of your body right now
mind is functioning within the realm of
your body you want to use it there
it is possible to do that it's not not
possible
it's just that
all kinds of wild and observed things
are believed if you trim those things
in many ways
knowingly or unknowingly many of you are
using this
you create what you want in the world
when you really want it
in a way it's simply your focus which
makes those things happen
maybe it is not as
tangible as it's in a cinema
but
every one of you to some extent you're
doing isn't it
how effectively do you do it
depends on uh
there are many things if i say things
that happen around me
they're too fairly tailish
i wouldn't believe such nonsense if
anybody told me so i won't tell you
because i don't want you to believe or
disbelieve those things but every day
people around me witness things which
they think is nothing short of a miracle
but there's no miracle
life is a big miracle
are you a part of it or are you out of
it that's a big question question is are
you consciously in it
or are you out of it that's a big
question
if you're in it
you're see if you use any thought
this is well he was asking how do we do
it in the beginning
suppose you generate a thought
have you noticed this suppose you
generate a thought
and then you invest your emotion in this
thought suddenly the thought becomes
boom huh
yes or no
right now i generate a thought oh she's
such a wonderful person
but now i invest my emotion into the
thought now suddenly
you are not just another person to me
you're something else to me
is it reality or no
just because you invested your emotion
into your thought
now there is a next thing
if you invest your life energies into it
consciously suddenly this will become
something else altogether
suddenly you become like
life is a play
is no more a struggle
because
miracles are always happening you put a
little seed it becomes a tree he eats a
noodle he becomes a man
i'm saying this is happening to
it's happening all the time just see you
put filth into the root just see it
becomes fragrance
is it is this not miracles and miracles
all over the place many people come to
me and say i want to be a millionaire i
i and there's a great song about i'm
going to be a millionaire and they read
things like the secret which says if you
want to be a millionaire just just wish
it and it will happen
and that's not quite enough i've worked
with many many many millionaires and i
became on myself quite a long time ago
now never having possibly thought that
could ever happen when i was at school i
was going to be a nanny that's how much
i thought i could earn in my lifetime
that's what i thought i was meant to be
but then i worked with so many
multi-millionaires and billionaires and
i really understand
how to attract money how to attract
wealth i'm going to take you through
today
why you haven't yet become a millionaire
there's several things that will stop
you here's the number one
you don't believe you are worth it you
may want money you may long for money
but if you have an inner belief that
says i'm not worth it not only won't you
attract that money if you did you would
get rid of all of it so if you wish to
become a millionaire you must decide
you're worth it the more
reasons you can decide you're worth it
the more you'll have that motivation
that fire that drive to go out
and make a lot of money the second thing
that will make you become and stay a
millionaire
is working out how much good you will do
with the millions that you make you see
bill gates what an amazing guy he says
that in 20 years
malaria won't exist because he is using
his money
to wipe out malaria that's an
extraordinary thing and he deserves all
the wealth he has for that reason alone
if you can think of something that you
could do or
the people you would help an impact by
becoming a millionaire the more reasons
you can come up with the more people you
can help the more reasons you will have
to become and stay a millionaire and
here's the third thing and this is so
important many people think well i'm
just going to float around and manifest
millions i'm just going to sit at home
on my sofa and manifest millions if you
want a job you go out and look for a job
if you want a new home you go out and
visit new homes you want a partner you
better go out and put yourself in front
of people
and if you want to make and keep
millions
you need to decide what are you going to
do
to make those millions what gift or
talent do you have that you can monetize
you may say i don't have anything but
that's not true
if you really take a while you can find
a gift a unique skill set you have that
you could monetize you see some of the
smartest people in the world they don't
invent a product they take an existing
product like james dice and he took a
hair dryer
he took a fan heater he took a vacuum
cleaner he took a hand dryer and he made
them better
and many many people take an existing
product to make it better and become a
millionaire that way it's not about
shall i invent something i don't have an
inventive mind i'm not creative
it's about an idea you may come up with
a new product you may take someone
else's product for instance shapewear
wasn't new when spanx came on the market
and became a
multi-multi-million dollar company they
didn't invent a new product well they
sort of did they took an existing
product they made it so much better
and you can do that too
but the biggest blocks i see with
budding millionaires are these things
one is
i'm gonna be a millionaire i'm going to
be a millionaire and they just try and
imagine in the future and the thing
about the mind is the human mind doesn't
future pace very well
one of the reasons depressed people
can't snap out of it is because they
can't future pace and by the way if this
is making sense to you please like
please share please subscribe to my
channel show to other people who also
want to make money why wouldn't you want
to make money you can do great things
for others when you make money but they
don't know how
they've been deluded by these
manifestation rooms sit at home and chan
on shanti and money will fall from the
heavens we all know
that's not true so if you want money you
must be able to
visualize but it must be now
you must be able to think of
how you're going to man you what could
you possibly do to make money
remember that woman who changed the face
of a floor mop they made a movie about
her and she became a millionaire and she
was a housewife but one day she was
mopping her floor you know this is not
really a good mop and she recreated and
reinvented a floor mop and has made
millions that way
but here's another big block you have to
work hard many people think well i'll
just manifest i just sit at home
the best plan in the world will not work
if you don't work
so people get this really weird belief
that people who make millions don't work
they just manifest it falls from the
heavens they float around doing a little
stuff here and there and that's not true
i work with millionaires and
billionaires and they do work hard they
work long
and they work hard on their way to
success they work a lot when they get
success
of course they can take time out but you
see when you do what you love and love
what you do it never really feels like
work i love what i do
i do what i love often say i feel like
i've never worked a day in my life
because i love what i do but really
i have worked out when i've written
books i've been writing for 12 hours a
day meeting deadlines i travel all over
the world through time zones giving
talks and sometimes that's tiring i plan
out my schools and i'm there teaching
but i love it so much it doesn't feel
like work but if you believe you can be
a millionaire
and not have to change anything or do
anything or work hard you will probably
never be a millionaire
you have to work hard you have to apply
yourself the best plan will not work if
you don't you have to have phenomenal
extraordinary self-belief
and finally you have to put yourself
around other people who've made money
ask them what did you do
what happened to you you see i met wayne
dyer many years ago and he said
something always remembered do not die
with your music still inside and i
thought wow
i'm one of the best therapists in the
world and i can't die with my therapy i
mean i need to create a course make a
school teacher to other people i was so
glad i listened to him
and i've listened to many people who say
the same thing i didn't go to university
i didn't have a child background i
wasn't born into money but i had a dream
a vision and i
married that vision to very hard work i
kept going
please don't think successfully will
never get rejected they do but they
bounce back they come back they have
unshakable
unwavering confidence they have drive
and determination
so take a few minutes and just get a
little notebook or on your phone write
out all the reasons why you would like
to be a millionaire
all the good things you could do if you
were a millionaire the people you could
help
and then decide
what industry you could go into you're
going to invent something create
something
and some of the smartest people create
things entirely by mistake look at what
other millionaires have done read some
books written by millionaires there are
many
read richard branson reed felix dennis
look at some stories of millionaires and
decide if they can do it i can do it
this is a template and i'm going to
follow that template and if you have the
belief the vision
the work ethic the drive
and the confidence you will become a
millionaire money is the exchange of
values
in fact the way a society spends
money
is
a clue
to their values
so right now most
wealthy nations and even some unwealthy
nations poor nations
are spending money on weapons on
mechanized death
on drugs
on alcohol
on gambling
on
sleazy stuff
and that only represents the collective
consciousness
of
bad money bad karma
and
therefore
stay away
from
any
way that
generates money
through harm
and this is what
the great teacher of all time
the buddha he said
right livelihood
so right livelihood is that kind of
livelihood
that
creates
joy in the world that
increases abundance in the world
increases
and improves the quality of life in the
world
okay
understand that when you're exchanging
money you're exchanging values there's a
clear separation between awareness and
the mind we're not the mind rather where
awareness moving through different areas
of the mind right so this is the most
important thing that i can share with
you and this is really the core uh it is
the foundation of everything that i do
teach
so once you realize that you're not the
mind but rather that you that rather
that your awareness moving through
different areas of mind you can control
where your awareness goes
and now i want to bring your attention
to another point this is a saying that
my guru said many many decades ago where
awareness goes energy flows right and
you've heard me share this many times as
well online
so once you know that you're not the
mind rather than your awareness and if
you can control where your awareness
goes you can control where your energy
is flowing now let's look at energy
energy is like water right whatever it
is your water will start to grow
energy works the same thing in the same
way too whatever it is you put energy
into will start to manifest in your life
so if you put energy into something
negative it'll grow and manifest in your
life you put energy into something
positive it'll grow and manifest in your
life one thing you want to do is move
your awareness there as you move your
awareness to those goals that's where
your energy is flowing as your energy
flows there you they start to manifest
in your life but one of the things you
want to do is to be mindful and be very
conscious of where you're spending your
energy you only have so much energy each
day right so you want to really assess
your life and look at the people and
things in your life and say okay i've
only got this much energy how can i take
this finite amount of energy that i have
and proportionately divide it into these
people and things
in my life that i care about so that i
can start to manifest them remember what
manifests in your life is
proportionately
is in proportion to what how much energy
that you're actually investing into
something so if you want something to
manifest in your life put energy into it
how do you put your energy into it you
move your awareness to that thing and
when you move your awareness there where
awareness goes energy flows
and that thing starts to manifest in
your life three things to keep in mind
purpose
focus simplify have a clear purpose
clear goals
focus on those things right focus on
those purposes and those goals
throughout the year always bring your
awareness back to them and simplify your
life simplify your life to the most
important people and the most important
things in your life so that you can take
the finite amount of energy
that you have and invest it into those
people and things into your into your
goals to manifest what you want to
manifest in 2019.
your energy dictates your results think
about it when you have felt
positive motivated energized ready to go
courageous bold you show up differently
right you show up differently than when
you're feeling depressed that it's not
going to work out
the negative self-talk someone like you
can't do it you're not getting any
momentum you're not getting the results
like think about your own mental state
when you are
trying to accomplish a goal and the
difference between when you have
positive energy versus negative energy
it has nothing to do with your skills
has nothing to do with your potential it
has everything to do with how you're
feeling right now
right it's why i say that lack of belief
is the world's number one problem
you don't believe in yourself enough you
don't have the right energy level and so
you don't go off and create even though
you've got it inside you to do it and
you've got the heart and the mission and
the care and the love and you want to do
it
so it's all about changing your energy
states
i think there's a misconception that
people who are high achievers wake up
and just feel energized and motivated
ready to go right today i did not wake
up and say yes
come on
[Music]
let's go take on the day i'm so excited
right that's not how i woke up today i
woke up it was dark outside it's snowing
as you can you can tell here right it's
snowing look at look at what look at
what nina's driving through
stay safe nina
both of our safety depends on it
she's driving through the the snow storm
it's dark outside
and i wake up and and the difference is
i don't i don't put my feet on the
ground to get all jazzed up and start
yelling about what a great day it's
going to be i wake up and i'm tired and
i'm like why is it so dark outside
why we have this snowstorm uh you know
i'm thinking about the call i had
yesterday with brendon burchard on zoom
and he's showing me his
tropical
puerto rican beach backdrop and i got
canadian snow happening here right now
the difference is
the people who you admire who have the
success who are the high achievers they
don't wake up
like there's a superhuman and extra
motivated
they're just like you the difference is
they have the habits and the routines
where they demand the energy from
themselves they create the energy for
themselves and so there's there's two
things that i want you to start thinking
about how do you do it right like okay
great heaven how do i do it how do i
actually change my energy how do i get
it so that i am feeling powerful bold
motivated confident excited on a daily
basis because it is possible and because
you know how great you feel and you know
the results that you get when you're
feeling that way
so two things that i want you to keep in
mind the first one is
having
something in your morning routine that
demands that from you so for me music is
the fastest way to change my state music
i have a playlist called the believe
playlist
it's hashtag believe all caps on my main
channel you can go find it that's the
music i listen to every day that may not
be the thing that gets you fired up but
it is for me
music is the fastest way to change your
state because there are some songs that
when they come on when you hear them
it just makes you want to move you might
get up and dance you might just be
nodding your head you might be tapping
your foot but there are some songs that
come on that make you want to move it
can't just be the same song every day
because then you're going to get sick of
it and bored of it but you make a
playlist of the different music that
when it comes on
it forces you to shift your state
we often put on the music for how we
currently feel
so when you're sad and low and depressed
or upset you put on music that makes you
feel
reinforced and you're sad and low and
depressed and upset states
when you're sad and low you don't put on
music to make you feel better you put on
music to keep you where you are that's
the problem that that then what it keeps
you where you are
right when you put on the music
for how you currently feel it keeps you
where you are where what you want to do
is use music to shift your state
so when you're feeling not so motivated
when you're feeling tired when you're
feeling low you put on music that gets
you up and what's going to happen you're
going to feel a little bit more up so
putting that as a part of your daily
routine daily daily daily daily daily
daily daily daily daily daily daily
routine it matters it makes a difference
if you if you started your day with
music that would make you feel
energized pumped up motivated ready to
go if you started your day with that
your day will look different your days
will look different your weeks will then
look different your months will look
different and the the things that you
accomplish will look dramatically
different okay so that's a daily basis i
need you to shift your morning routine
to incorporate something like that just
try it try for a week and see how you
feel it'll make a difference i promise
step number two is
reacting to the moment so that's what we
do in step number one we do on a daily
basis in the morning step number two is
when we have something that
we come across that
makes us feel
less confident that makes us feel scared
that is a big opportunity that makes us
question ourselves doubt ourselves when
you look at your calendar you look at
your emails you look at the results and
you see that you're not where you want
to be
the tendency is to beat ourselves up the
tendency is to play scared the tendency
is to act small the tendency is to
procrastinate and go do something else
right you know i've been there you've
been there maybe you are there right now
you know what i'm talking about
energy
is now the reason why we're staying
where we are so how do we shift our
energy
in those moments
one remind yourself that you do
difficult things
you do difficult things
that if it's hard that if it's scary
that it's difficult you're gonna do it
you're gonna do it you're gonna show up
you're gonna do it because you do
difficult things
it cuts the brain out of the equation
because now it's time to show yourself
what you can do
instead of overthinking over
procrastinating
and being overly scared when you think a
deliberate thought of what you want
um then law of attraction will employ
the universe
and all people circumstances and events
to
move you to what you've asked for and to
move what you've asked for to you
and so
if if if you think about that there is
just action
would be really really hard for you to
reach all of the people circumstances
and events manipulate all of them
to receive what you want and if you
really reflect well on your life and
things that have happened in your life
you'll kind of see
that
actually that happened for me
all i did was move to here or all i did
was move to there and i received what i
wanted
thought creates all of the appearances
in the world and thought creates
everything in your life
so it's pretty darn powerful right
and what you think about is what you get
what you focus on is what will manifest
in your life and everyone is manifesting
their day every single day we're doing
it um we are not aware of course
necessarily of thoughts but thoughts
come we energize them and then they will
manifest unless we
cancel that thought out
um with another thought with a thought
that contradicts it
but i remember lester levinson would say
every single thought manifests
and i just thought that was incredible i
had known the secret for years and years
and years and lester levinson was a real
master
um and he said every single thought
manifests and i was just wow
that's how powerful they are
so
so thoughts are your superpower
to be do and have
what you want to experience and have and
do in your life
and and so if you ask
um an athlete or if you talk to a coach
a really brilliant coach right of a
sports team then you will find that
visualization
and these principles that i'm talking
about are a big part of their training
they have to be they have to see
themselves winning the game they have to
see themselves winning the match there
is a really incredible tennis player
that's a very big fan
a um a champion tennis player that's a
really big fan of the secret who uses
the sacred this is what he does he sees
that he has won the match before he
walks out onto that court
and and it's the same for
um
for teams it's the same for athletes in
the olympic games
running a race and seeing that they've
won yes they run the race but
what has them win the race is that
they saw themselves winning before they
even got on the starting block
and they saw it and believed it and felt
it and so they just everything lined up
for them in the perfect way they drew
the perfect lane everybody else was was
moved in exactly the right position and
they got a really great start and they
won the race
and so
thought is just so so powerful so
athletes but also do you know the
astronauts in the apollo um
program did visualization
before they went to the moon and
they visualized
landing back on earth safely
and so that's how important the
visualization visualization is just
thought in pictures by the way it's it's
it's still thought it's just the same
thing okay it's just thought in pictures
so if you took a person who had
zero resistance
and you locked them in a room
you know if you took a person that had
zero resistance that person thought
about what they wanted zero resistance
lock them in a room what they wanted
will come to them
the universe will move people
circumstances and events and bring that
right to them in math it absolutely must
because if you have no resistance you
have unleashed a law that just cannot be
stopped
and so you will manifest it will come to
you science that demystifies the
mystical
and if you can combine a little quantum
physics with a little neuroscience with
neuroendocrinology with
psychoneuroimmunology the mind-body
connection epigenetics all of those
sciences point the finger at possibility
and
if you talk about religion if you talk
about culture if you talk about
tradition even spirituality i noticed
that you divide an audience
but science in a sense creates community
so people come
for all kinds of reasons and what i've
learned in the last year or so is that
what people really want is wholeness
because when we want something or in
separation or in lack right
and so when we started
experimenting with doing different
scientific measurements
one of the things we started to notice
is that when a person
somehow connects to something greater
and that has a influence on their
nervous system
the side effect is that they feel so
whole
so rejuvenated in that moment so blessed
by life
in that moment from an inner experience
that it's impossible for them to want i
mean how can you want
when you feel whole right and so when we
started looking at heart coherence and
we saw this
tremendous
changes in the
people's ability to be able to sustain
a state of mind a feeling in their heart
for an extended period of time
we have data to show you could be sick
and do that you could be a vegetarian
and do that you could be a carnivore and
do that you could be rich you could be
poor and it doesn't if you're skinny
overweight doesn't matter once you learn
that skill of self-regulation
and being able to experience a greater
level of wholeness
that if you can create from wholeness
instead of
separation or lack
you can produce greater effects
on the nature of reality so
we came from singularity and in when
your oneness or when your source
there's no separation between cause and
effect your thoughts create experiences
when you're in oneness we journey down
the density and now we're really
separate from source
and so the
what what happens between cause and
effect is called time
so we're here now
to prove to ourselves that the divine
lives in us
so why not practice
shortening
time
or the interval between cause the
thought and the effect the experience
and when you start seeing something
appear in your life as a result of you
at cause
you start getting more kind
more caring more loving more conscious
more present
because you feel more whole there's a
primary law called the law of vibration
the law of vibration decrees that
everything in this universe moves
nothing rests
um the body in a coffin is moving
probably you're probably thinking this
guy's smoking something like if the body
in a coffin wasn't moving how would it
ever change to dust
it's always moving it's always vibrating
everything vibrates we live in a notion
of motion take a microscope and look at
a solid wall
it's not solid and only appears to be
solid or perception problem there you'll
see the wall moving right in front of
your eyes there's a particle of energy
and they're dancing right before your
eyes that's a lot of vibration the law
of vibration decrees everything moves
nothing rests we literally live in a
notion of motion
now this physical instrument we're
living in we call our body is a
molecular structure and it's in a very
high speed of vibration
our brain is an electronic switching
station
when we activate brain cells we alter
the vibration in different parts of the
body i could not move my hand up and
down or my arm up and down without first
giving a message to my brain to do that
well the brain
activates cells in the body it sets up a
vibration in the body
the
vibration that the mind and body are in
is going to dictate what you attract
because when you put yourself in a
vibration what you're really doing is
put yourself on a specific frequency
that's what you do when you set a goal
most people set a goal and then wait for
it to happen and never going to happen
you've got to assume that it's already
happened you've got a picture of it in
your mind mentally it's already happened
it's happened because i've got the idea
in my conscious mind if i didn't have
the idea of my conscious mind i couldn't
talk to you about it the very fact i can
talk to you about it means that i've
already got it
then i've got to get emotionally
involved in it
i'm already emotionally involved in the
goal that i've got i've got it
intellectually i've got it emotionally
it's only a period of time till it moves
into form how does it move into form
well you attract whatever is required
for it to move into form you attract all
the energy that's necessary to produce
the physical result how do you do that
you do that by intellectually
emotionally staying in the vibration
of the good that you desire you see it
already in the present tense so that
keeps you on the frequency
and that frequency then dictates what
you're going to attract you can only
attract to you
what's in harmonious vibration with you
now if you're holding an image that you
can't get something you're on a
vibration
you're not going to get it but if you
can see yourself with it you know it's
coming to you you know it you know it's
only a period of time you're not quite
sure what the time is but you know it's
a period of time and bang that thing's
going to manifest in your life
you have controlled the vibration that
you're in the vibration then called the
frequency you put yourself in the
frequency that you good your desires on
let's suppose i want to have a lot of
money we're just talking about money now
this is a lot of money relative to let's
say
this there's one 100 here's 10 100 100.
so one's a lot relative to the other
neither one is a lot it just is
if i want to attract a lot of my i got
to see myself with a lot of money i
gotta mentally accept i've already got
it i don't let my bank account dictate
that i choose that
so i'm choosing myself to see myself
with a good already desire i'm on that
frequency now the trick is to stay on
that frequency
most people look at the results and they
let the results dictate the frequency
they're on that's why they keep getting
the same results
they have the image in their mind
they're already reached the goal they
want they're already successful and
somebody else comes along and say well
you haven't got those results
in my mind i have but they're not
looking in my mind they're looking at my
present results and then pretty soon i
start listening to them i think god
they're right i look at my results i
haven't got it
do you see why we keep getting this poor
results
you've got to see yourself with the good
you desire you've got to hold that image
in your mind you've got to know it's
going to come and that will attract
everything that's necessary see nothing
is created or destroyed everything's
already here if not in one frequency
certainly in another or not in one state
certainly in another we've got to get on
the frequency of the good that we desire
the basic thing that neville taught me
and a lot of this is from the teachings
of neville
neville goddard who died in the 1970s he
he basically said that
all of us have within us this
amazing capacity to manifest and attract
anything that we want into our life so
how we call it what what words that we
use we have to be able to say um you
know in the secret they say you you get
what you want you know and what is
missing and what neville said and what
has come to mean what i got from the i
am discourses and what i get from the
new testament which i read before i did
it is that you you say
i will attract into my life what i am
not what i want and i am capable of
attracting all things that
that the source is capable of attracting
so
that's the difference it's like you get
what you are rather than what you want
so you want to become
you can't go around and ask these divine
beings you know angels whatever you want
to call them who are right here
you have to become like they are
that when you're when you become angelic
when you become a divine being yourself
when you are giving when you are serving
when you are in that place they will
come to you that's what happened to you
in india you then begin to see yourself
in everything that's what the tao de
ching teaches as well they call it your
original nature your original nature is
reverence for all of life gentleness
kindness and service towards others
that's lao tzu 500 years before the
birth of christ saying that's our
original nature yes reverence for all of
life gentleness kindness service towards
other giving offering serving and when
you get to that place where you no
longer have any judgment within you
towards any of god's children that means
no condemnation no criticism no judgment
towards anyone and if enough of us get
this message oprah if enough of us get
on that's just what my mission is is
just to teach people that you are love
you are divine put that into your
imagination i am i am well i am happy i
am content i am fulfilled even if your
senses tell you that you're depressed
one of your people that called me when
we did a pre-interview on here said well
if i if i'm feeling depressed i'm
supposed to fool myself and say i am
feeling well even you can't choose
another thought that's what i've had
absolutely and it's like you don't say i
am depressed because if you say i am
depressed you connect with depression
and the universal source god whatever
you want to call it will align in such a
way to offer you whatever it is
yeah here's some more depression i am
unhappy i am depressed i am so by
placing into your imagination what you
want and assuming the feeling of that
wish is already fulfilled you go through
your life feeling that when enough of us
do that we will we will transform this
planet i'm telling you it can be done
eighty percent of you who use a vision
book or a vision board say
it changed me
i've told you about my vision board i
had it above my bed i wanted to get
married i wanted to go to africa and
here's a picture of my wedding was such
a here's a picture of me in africa
holding a lion that had been raised from
a cub with a family and it it lived
there and it was amazing but i made
these come true i had that vision in my
mind i held that vision i'm
getting married i'm going on safari
and you're never given a vision without
an idea of making it real because what
you want wants you
what you are moving towards is moving
towards you have a vision or a dream or
a wish inside you
get it out of you
put it on paper look at it touch it
read it then you are making it real when
you can look at your vision write all
over your vision
write on it change it mix it up it's not
a dream
you're making it real your potential
expands as you move towards it this will
expand your potential
when you move your mind to a new
dimension it never moves back
never right i wish i dream right i am i
do i can i will i always
i always exercise i can
fit exercise into my life i am
a fit person
i always pick healthy food i can find
healthy food wherever i go i'm the kind
of person that makes eating well a
master priority i can i do i am i always
inspire your mind turn it on with
exciting words turn it on the other
thing about this vision book is it makes
you accountable as you look every day at
the pictures of someone doing yoga
or eating fruit you think well
i better stop looking at that and start
doing it every day as you look at
pictures somebody working from home
socializing looking after their body
horse riding
hiking
making salads as you look at it enough
you become inspired
to take action it motivates you it
inspires you it fills up your mind with
what you want
and it fills you up with a desire a
passion
it motivates you conditions you programs
you compels you to go after what you
want
it holds you accountable
and it's so easy
so don't make it perfect i am a powerful
manifester you have to meet the
vibration you can't be above or below it
it's just what i was talking about
negative energy
positive energy in order to draw the
thing to you that you want to come you
can't want it so much that you fear that
you won't get it you have to want it so
in order for me to be on your vision
board you must have put it there and
then you let it go yes and then you
weren't thinking about it every day
every day every day because you can't it
doesn't come to you that way you have to
do it and you have to put it and then
you have to meet that vibration you
prepare yourself to be there and ready
if you're caught and thinking negatively
about the world and about yourself this
is so important
what would change inside of you if you
looked around
and you wrote down five things that
you're grateful for about the world now
this for me
is part of the secret to the law of
attraction it's the foundation is
gratitude it's your way of being must be
grateful in order to attract new things
there's so many things in my life that i
should not have attracted
because i didn't have the skills because
i didn't have the tools because i didn't
have the education because i didn't have
the money because i didn't have the
resources
so many things that i shouldn't have
attracted but because i had the
foundation of gratitude
passion joy curiosity those things
started to come to me and they can come
to you as well if you come from that
place of gratitude as your foundation
so you want to think about what are
these things that are important to me in
my life you know it can be simple things
it could be like this cup of coffee that
i have right now it can be that i have a
roof over my head that i've got quality
friends that i'm healthy
you know that i'm walking in nature
today it doesn't have to be
some grandiose thing that's happened to
you to be grateful for i'm so grateful
for
these little present moments
with people that i care about to spend
an hour on the beach to go for a walk
with a friend to have a good
conversation with someone and talk about
something that i'm going through for me
that's just as meaningful
the moments in between the big moments
are just as meaningful so write down
these things or think about these things
this is something i embed in my daily
life when i wake up i think about what
i'm grateful for when i go to sleep i i
think about and reflect on the things
i'm grateful for from that day and it's
just my way of being for as much as i
can now i'm not perfect i make mistakes
and there's some times i'm negative
but it's something that i try to really
focus on as much as possible so instead
of saying that you're not enough
that you don't deserve success what if
you looked in the mirror on a daily
basis i dare you to look in the mirror
on a daily basis and say i am enough and
i do deserve
the results that i want to create in my
life because i show up because i'm
consistent because i work hard because i
care about my work
if you looked in the mirror and you did
this consistently for 30 days and you
actually
use the word action in attraction and
you put it into practice on a daily
basis towards that growth
i'd be amazed to see what you attract
and what you manifest in your life
manifesting is acquiring the experience
of what it is that you want to feel and
being and living and believing in that
experience and then allowing that
experience to come into form sometimes
we manifest things far beyond our
wildest dreams so sometimes if we have a
vision of something it happens in a far
greater way so we want to stay open yep
so we can say i want that macbook air
but maybe we get that macbook air that's
a little bit bigger than we thought yeah
or maybe it comes with an extra little
gift yeah but allowing ourselves to be
open this or something more manifesting
is very creative it is the process of
using your power energy and being in
that presence of your high-powered
energy and allowing that energy to
co-create with the energy that's around
you so you're vibrating at a high
frequency i'm vibrating at high
frequency we've done a lot of work we've
cleaned up a lot of our own crap we
believe in ourselves today and that that
energy of believing in ourselves has
attracted us together today and brought
us into this space where we together are
co-creating and teaching if i hadn't
cleaned up my side of the street and if
i didn't believe in myself the way i do
i would never have manifested being on
marietv miracles occur naturally and
when they're not occurring something has
gone wrong
that's interesting it's a good one right
so what happens is that that
synchronicity that flow that effortless
action that just sort of allowing oh i
was thinking about that and it just
showed up that's how life is supposed to
be
we get in the way our negative belief
systems our fears our
anxiety our our anger towards the past
that future tripping and projecting all
of that energy gets in the way of
allowing all of the miracles to occur
naturally the first type of
manifestation is to get very very clear
you must be clear because if you are
unclear you'll start to call in some
things that are not really what you want
you'll be confused uh the other piece is
that once you're clear you can also then
get clear about all the ways that you
don't believe i once heard a definition
of health that made a lot of sense to me
good health it said
is having no fatigue
having a good appetite
going to sleep and awakening easily
having a good memory
having good humor
and having precision in thought and
action
not being klutzy
being honest
humble
grateful and loving
how healthy are you
i do not heal anyone
the work i do is to help people
understand how their own mental patterns
are constantly creating their own life
experiences
all of them
the good experiences
and the so-called bad experiences
and also
how these same mental patterns
are contributing to the ease
and dis-ease
in their bodies
we do not want to be ill
and yet we need every disease we
have it is the body's way of telling us
that we have a false idea in
consciousness
our body is telling us
we are on the wrong track
and need to change the way we think
every illness
is a lesson
for us to learn
please do not just complain i want to
get rid of this condition
it will not create the healing you want
nor will you learn the lesson you need
to learn
this is not a time for condemnation
or for creating more guilt
we are just looking at what needs to be
released
this is a time for healing
for making our lives and our bodies
whole
i know
you have within you all that you need to
accomplish this
once we begin to understand this process
we are able to take conscious control
of the changes we wish to make in our
lives
this is a very exciting process
and becomes one of the most important
adventures in our lives
i believe there is a center of wisdom
within each one of us
and when we are ready to make positive
changes in our lives
we attract whatever we need to help us
something inside of you has shifted
and the healing process has already
begun
you might even say that to yourself now
i have already begun
the healing process
the body like everything else in life
is a mirror of our inner thoughts and
beliefs
the body is always talking to us if we
will only take the time to listen
every cell
responds to every single thought you
think
and every word you speak
continuous modes of thinking and
speaking
produce body behaviors and postures and
eases or diseases
the person who has a permanently
scowling face
did not produce that
by having joyous loving thoughts
older people's faces and bodies
show so clearly a lifetime of inner
dialogue
how will you look
when you are elderly
you see it is my belief that it is our
birthright to be totally healthy
and totally fulfilled
in every area of our lives take a nice
deep breath
and if possible
allow yourself to be in a comfortable
position
just let these ideas wash over you
only those ideas that are right for you
will be accepted by you
it doesn't matter whether you understand
them all or not
or if they make sense to you right now
your subconscious mind will hear and
record whatever you need
i believe that all illness is
self-created
not that we say i want to have this
illness
but we create a mental atmosphere where
this dis-ease can grow and flourish
our internal mental dialogue
reacts in every cell
in the body
i heard a physician say recently
if the surgeon operates on a patient
without doing something to help them
change the cause of the disease
then all the doctor is doing is
prolonging the life of the patient
until the patient can create another
dis-ease
you see we need to do more than just
treat the symptom
we need to eliminate the cause of the
dis-ease
and for that we need to go within
ourselves where the process of illness
began
it is my belief that we are each
responsible for every experience in our
lives
the best and the worst we all create our
experiences by the thoughts we think and
the words we speak
the universe totally supports our
internal dialogue
our subconscious mind accepts as truth
whatever we choose to believe
you can say it either way
they both mean that what i believe about
myself and about life becomes true for
me
what you choose to think about yourself
and about life becomes true for you
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to learn to manifest what you want
in life check the video right there next
to me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there you go
through your life feeling that when
enough of us do that we will we will
transform this planet i'm telling you it
can be done the vibration that the mind
and body are in is going to dictate what
you attract